in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Colton
and Alicia are with us hey guys how are
you doing well sir how are you better
than I deserve welcome where do y'all
live San Antonio oh cool nice city love
San Antonio and all the way to Nashville
to do a debt free scream yes sir love it
how much you paid off about 80 here
about seventy eight thousand dollars
good how long did this take you about
nine months and we also cash flowed an
additional about $10,000 worth of things
on top of that whoa
and your range of income during this
time between 90 and 125 okay all right
so you must have either sold some stuff
or I had some money and savings you
throughout this re-enlistment bonus
really helped too ah okay thank you for
you thank you for your service thank you
very cool so what kind of debt was the
78,000 we had two cars four credit cards
a TSP loan and the family loan two cars
credit cards a TSP loan you were normal
yes sir you were regular people
oh my goodness so you decided nine
months ago to go on this journey to be
weird yes completely out of that no
financial stress now you're in a
position to build wealth tell me what
happened what started this journey so
you'll have to bear with me and if I
break down he'll take over for me but
our journey goes back to 2015 we started
to try and grow our family mm-hmm and
the doctors told us that I couldn't have
kids and then the surprise August of
2016 we were pregnant oh my gosh we were
so happy
um the pregnancy was really hard mm-hmm
and the end of January 2017 23 weeks
pregnant I was diagnosed with a really
rare severe form of free eclampsia all
that bikini life-threatening mmm so we
had to deliver our daughter Shalimar
early and she only lived for three hours
and when she died I had to put her
expenses on a credit card and he didn't
even know I had done that I felt like
the worst mom in the world and the same
day we also found out that we were both
carriers for cystic fibrosis and so we
went to the fertility clinics and all
the doctors and they were saying that
the treatments for all of this were
going to be $7,000 $18,000 and I was
like we don't have that kind of money
we're doing everything everybody says
that we're supposed to do we have a
great credit score you know we've got
the new cars we're making all our
payments but I don't even have the money
to bury my child and so I started
looking on the internet and I was
stressed buying things on Amazon and one
of the things that was suggested while I
was buying money things was the
Financial Peace University so I got that
and while I was at home recovering I
started going over the program and I
knew that we needed to do this and I
knew he wouldn't read a book so I got
him the CDs and I asked him if he would
listen to them on the way to work and he
jumped right on board yeah what a
heartbreaking thing to go through I'm so
sorry
well it's up but boy the wake-up call
was thorough huh yes yes sir yeah and
when it's something like that that just
is already your hearts broken but then
on top of that it's like I got to put
this on our credit card oh my gosh that
just that seals it so what that tells me
is you are done you will never go back I
mean this is not a this is not a an
intellectual exercise for you this was
an emotional exercise for you you said
we're never I am never gonna be in a
position like that again that's the kind
of experience Sharon and I had
emotionally it was obviously a different
a different set of events but I'm so
sorry I went through that what a
heartbreaking thing thank you and and
you made it you made through the story
good for you we did those strong yeah on
top of that while we were going through
the journey we started to look around my
husband and I were both active-duty Air
Force and we saw other people that were
struggling with money
and other people that were trying to do
the fertility thing too
and we were like well if we can do it
they can do it and so we contacted your
military coordinator and you hooked us
up with a kit yeah and that first class
was such a big success that both of our
wing chaplains started to adopt the
program and now they're offering it
quarterly to people in our in our wings
and it's really spreading and we've done
three so far and the next one is in
September and all because of you guys
thank you thank you so much thank you
sir
that's that's pretty amazing that's some
good good work you're doing and lots of
people have a lot of different lives on
a lot of different stories to tell just
because of that Wow well done well done
well I'm proud of you it's some hard
times to walk through hard times to walk
through and and nine months later
everything is different huh yes sir
how's it feel done I'll have a payment
in the world the lack of stress is
incredible
it feels like you could take on anything
that comes your way yeah yeah it's a
mission readiness issue I think very
much a lot a lot of the commanders and
you know brass that we've talked to
about it in the different in the
different branches of the military tell
us that it's a mission readiness issue
it really is when people are you know
because it's one thing if you if you
work in corporate America and you fly a
desk for a living and you know you got a
little financial stress and you don't
keep your eye on your business that's
one thing but when you guys don't keep
your eye on the business people get hurt
it's not a good thing at all
so so very cool I'm happy that you guys
have turned this around very very cool
so now that you're helping spread the
word you got Financial Peace University
going all through your wing and
everything else what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is you
paid off seventy eight thousand dollars
and nine months for me it's
communication communicating on the goals
communicating on what you're feeling at
a time especially going through this
there's a lot of stress while you're
doing the whole beans and rice rice and
beans so just communicating yeah and
what about you Alicia just common goals
I mean you have to be on the same team
and you
to be fighting the same fight otherwise
and you're not gonna make ground either
way and I mean like once he was on board
we were just like we just took off right
away and sold my Jeep and fun stuff hmm
yeah that's how you move the needle so
fast you just got so intense yeah but I
mean with with what you all went through
it I mean it just it's like a would one
of those old wood-burning tools when I
was a kid it just it burns it into your
soul done that I mean it's like I am
never gonna be here again yeah you know
you're just it's like you know you just
you you it's it's a it's a very intense
thing and so it's a horrible way to get
there but but but the benefit of it is
is that it you will never go back
correct
you will never and we're working on
changing our whole family everybody for
Christmas got like the Total Money
Makeover a life not theirs and so to see
the rest of our family starting to turn
things around to it's been such a
blessing man you guys are amazing
well thank you so much thank you I'm
glad some good came out of that tragedy
so and then you guys are the good that's
good stuff very very well done
well we've of course got a copy of Chris
Hogan's book for you retire inspired and
that's the next chapter in your story to
be millionaires yes they're outrageously
generous and you are on your way you're
gonna be able to do things and already
are doing things that most people never
dream of doing all right
Colton and Alyssa San Antonio Texas
seventy eight thousand ten in nine
months making 90 to 125 count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one
very
oh my goodness Wow
absolutely amazing